I'm Dr. Jordan B.
Peterson,
a psychology professor at the University
of Toronto in Canada.
I'm going to tell you the story behind
the self authoring suite website.
A few years ago I realized that the
students in my classes had written
essays on all sorts of subjects in grade
school and college.
However,
they'd never been asked to write
thoughtfully about themselves,
about their own past experiences,
personalities,
and visions for their futures.
Upon reflection,
just lack of opportunity.
He struck me as strange to say the least
since there's nothing more important to
get straight than your own personal
experience.
At the same time,
I was speaking with managers at various
companies about how to hire more
effective workers.
They were much more interested in how to
improve the performance of poorly
performing people they had already
hired.
I didn't have much to tell them at the
time because improving people is very
difficult.
Nonetheless,
the two problems stuck in my mind,
so I started to search for psychological
interventions that could be used widely
and practically to clarify and improve
people's lives.
I already knew that people lived inside
the stories they told about themselves
and that they use those stories to
interpret everything around them.
Well,
considering this,
I came up on Dr. James Pennebaker's
research conducted at the University of
Texas at Austin.
Dr Pennebaker tested Sigmund Freud's
theory that the release of emotions
related to traumatic events could be
curative.
He had his students write for three days
for 15 minutes a day about the most
upsetting experiences of their lives.
While the control group wrote about
ordinary daily activities,
those in the former group experience
longterm improvements in their
psychological and physical health after
a brief dip in mood,
not so much because of the expression of
pent up feelings,
however,
but because they drew more specific
causal conclusions about what had
happened to them in the past.
Dr. Laura King had her subjects right
about their ideals and future goals
instead that they experienced the same
benefits.
Our research team specifically tested
the effects of the future authoring
program.
Part of the self authoring suite related
to goal setting have mcgill university
in Montreal,
Canada,
and the Rasmus University in Rotterdam.
It academically struggling.
Miguel students increased their grades
by 25% in one year and decrease their
dropout rates from 30% to zero.
The same thing happened at Erasmus
University with more than 1200 business
students.
These affects you not just apply to
students either.
Dr. Frank Smith,
one of the world's outstanding
industrial psychologists as demonstrated
that participating in such programs
makes all kinds of people substantially
more effective or whatever they are
doing.
People who complete sex programs appear
to benefit because the careful
articulation of their experiences past,
present and future decreases misery
related to threat and uncertainty and
increases happiness and hope which
people experience when they progressed
towards somewhere they truly want to be.
When complicated experiences are
carefully put into words,
the manner in which they are represented
in the brain changes.
They moved from the areas associated
with stressfully motion demanding
constant physical readiness to the areas
associated with detailed comprehension
and understanding just makes articulate
people less stressed and more informed
about how to be successful now and in
the future.
It is for these reasons that we
developed a self authoring suite,
a set of four interactive online writing
programs and are offering them to anyone
who wants to concentrate on improving
his or her life.
If you want to understand yourself
better,
become less anxious and happier and
commit yourself more firmly to your
education,
career or your relationships,
these programs will help a lot.
Each of the programs is composed of a
series of interactive web pages,
the present you a specific personal
questions.
This simplifies and guides the difficult
process of personal writing.
Each program requires careful thought
and take several hours to complete.
It is better to write over a number of
days so that you have time to think and
because sleep aids the process,
the writing is challenging,
but the experimentally documented
benefits are worth it.
The past authoring program helps you
write an autobiography.
It will present you with pages like
this,
introducing you to the program
and providing psychologically sound
advice and information.
It will then ask you to start writing,
dividing your life into seven eip,
pocs or sections,
and describing the important experiences
of each the to present.
All three programs help you address your
personality,
faults and capitalize on your virtues.
When you start either of these programs,
you will also be presented with
instruction pages.
Then you'll be provided with a list of
adjectives,
some of which will accurately define you
and be asked to select six to nine
describing your faults.
If you're feeling up to a challenge or
your virtues,
if you could use a boost,
he will then be asked to rank order
these adjectives and to write a
paragraph describing a time when each
had a specific effect on your life.
The future authoring program helps you
define the future that would work best
for you three to five years down the
road,
and just as importantly to describe the
future you want to avoid.
It starts with some questions like these
which will start you thinking in the
right direction.
Then it will ask you to write freely
about what you want and don't want and
about how to justify your decisions and
stay on the right track.
The programs contain much more detailed
than this brief summary Presents.
Here are the sorts of additional
questions you will be asked to consider.
What were your 10 most important
experiences?
Were they positive or negative?
How did each experience change you or
your view of other people?
Were there things that you should have
done differently?
Are you the life of the party?
Do you feel comfortable around people?
Do you think before you act?
Are you full of ideas?
Are you a sensible person?
Do you do things according to a plan?
Are you too quiet around strangers?
Do you daydream too much?
What is one thing that you could do
better?
What do you want to learn about?
How should you handle your drinking or
drug use?
Describe your ideal social life.
You may choose to complete any or all of
the four programs.
You'll be given a confidential user name
and account password and your writing
will be securely stored.
Once you have completed each program,
you'll receive an organized
comprehensive email laying out the work
that you have done.
You can return to the programs in the
future to edit and update your work.
Many people do not understand who they
are,
where they are,
or where they are going.
In consequence,
instead of attempting those actions that
would make their lives as valuable as
possible,
things just happened to them and they're
often not good
carefully answering all the questions in
the self authoring suite in your own
words,
we'll clear the fog from your vision,
make you healthier and stronger,
and increased the chances that you will
exist in a manner that justifies all the
trouble that life inevitably presents.
This will help you be a good person for
yourself and for other people.
Carve yourself a new and better you.
There's no sense slouching around
miserably when you can aim for what you
should have and get it.
Good luck with the programs.